we're gonna step away from the
coronavirus crisis for just a moment we
want to focus on our women in uniform
who serve at home and abroad as we
celebrate Women's History Month
that's this March women make up about
17% of personnel across the military
branches but that number is rising and
with it the number of female leaders yay
Charlie d'Agata travelled to the USS
Mount Whitney in the Mediterranean Sea
to meet Navy Vice Admiral Lisa M friend
caddy good morning from the deck of the
USS Mount Whitney the flagship of the
u.s. Navy 6th fleet but the focus today
is on the commander of the fleet who not
long ago would have been forbidden from
even serving on this ship that is the
sound of a bosun's pipe and this
ceremony isn't held for just any top
brass three-star Vice Admiral Lisa and
Frank Hetty is not just the
highest-ranking officer on board but the
commander of the entire 6th
the only female fleet commander in the
US Navy could you have dreamed way back
when when your career began you'd be
here never dreamed it because when
Admiral Frank had he joined women
weren't even allowed on combat vessels
let alone to hold any leadership
positions and joining at all came by
chance well it's kind of a funny story I
didn't really have this dream when I was
growing up in fact I really wanted to be
you yes like me multi-award-winning
foreign correspondent she got her
journalism degree at Northwestern
University where she joined the ROTC
program to help pay her way and rest is
history
34 years later Here I am but 34 years
ago little did she know things were
about to change execute in the same year
of his inauguration 1993 President Bill
Clinton repealed the prohibition of
women serving on combat vessels law
changed policy changed and I was
assigned in my first combatant ship then
I decided all right now I want to
command a combatant ship and then after
that I want to command a squadron and
then really aspirational command a fleet
a fleet tasked with keeping watch over
one of the most volatile regions on the
planet
so you see adversaries in in Europe you
see there the Russia threat you look to
the Middle East you see everything that
emanates out of the Middle East and the
Mount Whitney is one of the most
sophisticated command and control ships
ever commissioned we got a rare glimpse
at the very heart of it the Joint
Operations Center basically this is
where
the ships embarked of an mh-60 Sierra
Seahawk helicopter which transports
Admiral Frank petty and staff to and
from the Sixth Fleet headquarters in
Naples Italy
[Music]
adversaries like Russia increasingly
belligerent since invading Crimea
stepping up war footing at its naval
base in Syria both under the watch of
the 6th fleet do you feel the pressure I
mean we all feel that pressure and what
we do in support of our national
security interests makes a difference
every day our forces matter and the
message that we send by what we do
matters it matters to senior chief petty
officer patience ray and lieutenant
Stephanie Wexler how important is it to
see women in leadership roles for
somebody in your position I think it's
very important I think that ultimately
people do need to see people who look
like them well you want good quality
people regardless of gender it's still
important because there's some
fundamental piece that I think speaks to
everyone that says that could be me
someday she really engages with as many
people as she can yes she's very
approachable she actually does come and
see say hello how are you how are your
family it is a very stratified command
structure there's a formality at the top
but she sort of breaks down those
structures it seems to be fair though
sir I wouldn't say that she completely
breaks it down you still remember when
you're speaking to her that's a
three-star Admiral so but it doesn't
there's it doesn't hurt to treat people
like humans admiral fanchetti says that
human touch is intentional retaining
servicemembers is a lot easier to do if
they feel part of something and maybe
even make a career of it I ever get
tired of this I never get tired of this
how could you get tired of this view
as for what's on your own horizon I
don't really have any control over that
horizon so right now I'm just doing my
best learning everything I can and I
know that whatever comes next would be
the right thing for me the right thing
for the Navy right thing for my family
and for our nation now the numbers show
that the US military in general may have
some way to go in actively recruiting
young women but the Vice Admiral told us
she hopes that she serves as an example
of what's now possible for CBS this
morning Charlie d'Agata aboard the USS
Mount Whitney in the Mediterranean love
those three stars on her helmet
I love how the lieutenant pointed it out
to be clear sir used to know you're
talking to I love Charlie a multi award
winner or in correspond what I love
about the commander's career path is she
wanted to do one thing she pushing her
dream to ended up being elsewhere I
think it's a great lesson for people out
there a dream Tony that she said she
didn't even know she had I think it's so
great that's what I think I said she Oh
Admiral Frank cannon Thank You Charlie
d'Agata henceforth formerly known as
multi award-winning foreign cars ha ha
ha
there you go